shanks vs luffy usa vs loki and
blackbeard waiting for his turn to
collect the strongest mythical zone
devil fruit even though wano is already
one of my favorite arcs in all of one
piece there has been no other arc i've
been as excited for and as anxious about
as the legendary kingdom of the mighty
giants elbaf because i'm convinced that
it's not only going to be the straw
hat's next destination after wano but
also the most important arc for the end
game of one piece after love tale itself
and today i want to try and predict as
well as i can how all these epic events
might unfold themselves during the
albert arc
hi my name is even though as someone so
obsessed with japanese culture that i
packed my stuff and moved to tokyo i've
been enjoying the ongoing japan inspired
wanokuni arc a lot it has been going on
for a while now to be precise it started
with chapter 909 back in july of 2018
which was four years ago i wasn't even
thinking about doing youtube at that
point so as much as i'm enjoying what i
can just hope to be the actual climax of
this arc at the moment i found it
incredibly refreshing to look ahead and
think about what the future of one piece
might bring and in that hopefully not
all too distant future i see a rocky
island in the shadow of a gigantic tree
inhabited by the most powerful mythical
beings imaginable
epic viking music
instead of japanese mythology sakura
trees and samurai will have nordic
mythology snowy mountain peaks and
vikings and just so you know next to
japan of course norway has been my
favorite place i've ever lived and
honestly i think elbaf's layout will be
heavily inspired by that with icy winds
long nights and banquets with a lot of
alcohol the most stunning place i have
ever laid eyes on are the so-called
lofoten islands in the far north of
norway please tell me that this doesn't
look exactly like what we've seen of
elbaf's coastline so far honestly if
there's just one place on earth i really
have to recommend you must see it is
this one okay so now that we've set the
right mood how likely is it that we will
even go to elbaf in the first place
after all it hasn't been officially
confirmed at all if we're actually going
to go there and author either oda has to
keep pushing back his goal for finishing
one piece as it is so the only way for
an albert arc to exist is if it heavily
contributes to the climax of the series
pushes the story and its development
further and has a clear connection to
wano and for full disclosure it is of
course absolutely possible that elbaf
will be skipped or just be referenced in
passing biota as well now being said
there is a really good reason why me and
large parts of the fandom find that
possibility unlikely and basically take
a visit to elbaf for granted it has been
foreshadowed as far back as chapter 115
when the straw has arrived on little
garden on little garland little garden
where they met the giant story and
braggy
there are so many important character
arcs that are all bound to culminate
into elbaf at the center of it all is
undoubtedly usopp i've just recently
made a full video on usopp's character
development and why i think elbaf will
be his big arc so if you haven't seen it
already i strongly recommend that you
check that one out afterwards but all
you have to know for now is that usop
has been forging relationships and
friendships with the giants of elba
throughout the story where he has gained
their respect and loyalty and on more
than one occasion has promised to go to
albath one day to become a brave warrior
of the sea like his giant friends
[Music]
and don't worry i'll be telling you what
i believe will happen with usopp in just
a little bit the other character that
has major connections to the giants is
of course none other than the empress
herself big mom who not only grew up on
elbaf but who also has a crazy obsession
with integrating the giants into her
ideal world even though the giants
despise her for her actions as a child
but surprisingly enough big mom isn't
the only emperor with ties to this
islands in my character analysis on
shanks i explored the strong ties shanks
has to nordic mythology in fact not only
does he sail on a viking ship but his
entire character seems to be inspired by
the nordic god tear and in that same
video i explored the idea that elbaf
might be in fact under the protection of
the red hair pirates and zen zuano will
be the arc where luffy will finally rise
into the ranks of the yonko i think it's
about time that he met his mentor again
now that he's become the great pirate
that shanks wanted him to be
and aside from all these character arcs
it seems like albath might be home to
the father tree atom from which what the
thousand sunny was made as well it has
been speculated that this tree might be
the main entrance to the sky islands but
honestly no matter what it will turn out
to be it will play some important role
in the lore of the story should it
actually be there and if you watch
really carefully in the next clip you
can see something that looks
suspiciously like a giant tree trunk in
the back
and uh this might be a bit of a stupid
argument maybe but if oda had planned to
skip going to albev altogether he surely
would have shown it off to us in all its
glory instead of shrouding it in so much
mystery and barely giving us a glimpse
of its shoreline oh and we have this
pretty telling color spread of the straw
hats as vikings so with all that being
said i now want to share with you my
timeline of the things that could and in
my opinion should happen during the
albert arc and while i base all of this
on everything that has been foreshadowed
in the story keep in mind that i could
be completely wrong about this that
being said i do believe that there is a
pretty good chance a good chunk of this
will happen in some way or form so after
a long and gruesome battle we finally
depart wano luffy has defeated kaido and
established himself as an emperor and
the borders of wano have finally been
opened with the monster trio incapable
of doing anything for a while after
their big fights it was the straw hat
grand fleet that had to come to the help
when it looked like both luffy and kaido
were about to be disposed of this could
either be by the world government or
blackbeard this way the crew is saved
and wano is able to start rebuilding
itself now while the grand fleet had
sworn their loyalty to luffy most of
them are actually loyal to usopp as well
[Music]
and with the big three knocked out for a
while usopp finds himself in command by
accident as a substitute captain
starting off his arc by fulfilling two
of his lies leading thousands of men and
being a captain however since it was by
accident usop will most likely do a
pretty bad job leading at first
after arriving on elbaf i can see the
first half of the arc focusing on the
culture of the giants and the issues of
their nation during whole cake island
prince loki seems to have been set up as
the main villain here
loki who we know from nordic mythology
as a trickster and manipulator has
somehow managed to take control of the
giants possibly getting rid of dorian
bragy and has even convinced them to
forget their hatred of big mom and made
them allow him to marry lola though she
refused in the end now loki is
confronted by another trickster and
manipulator usop who has gained respect
and loyalty among many of the albaf
giants both of them might be quite
similar in terms of their personality
but while usa values bravery and wants
to be like the giants loki mostly values
himself
at this point i think it would be a
waste if oda didn't give usop a mjolnir
like hammer to parallel thor vs loki
[Music]
soon usopp tries to expose loki's
trickery possibly triggered by the
arrival of big mom siding with loki and
maybe lola who big mom will try to marry
off once again usop counts on the other
straw hats to stop loki which doesn't
happen with luffy zara and sanji still
out of the game and so finally after
seeing the giant suffer and being backed
by nami to help lola he ends up doing
the right thing taking matters into his
own hand and challenging loki to a duel
now we have the classic theme of david
with his slingshot versus the giant
goliath the fight itself goes on just as
you imagine usob will try using tricks
hammers dials and even his observation
haki against loki but despite a few
minor successes nothing really works
he's a giant after all finally loki
hurts usop so badly that he almost seems
to win the fight and this in combination
with usop's previous failure as a leader
pushes him into despair this is where
usop's congress hockey kicks in
something that i discussed in detail in
this previous video
[Music]
using conqueror's haki usop knocks down
the giant prince of elbaf terrifying all
those watching and earning the respect
of the giants who will call him a brave
warrior of the sea a tale so epic that
it's only worthy of such a legendary
character as god usopp and thus another
lie has come true uzop having conquerors
haki not only does he liberate the
giants of elbaf but he also gains the
right to lead the grand fleet and the
giants numbering 8 000 men into battle
behind luffy at the end of the story and
most importantly he convinces everyone
to subscribe to this channel a true
legend this is where the second half of
this arc begins luffy and the others
just got back on their feet in time to
witness usop's victory amid the
celebrations a ship arrives at the
harbour a
viking ship luffy turns around and sees
shanks and his men walking towards them
luffy of course starts grinning and runs
towards shanks shouting and waving but
the emperor just pulls out his sword
with a stern face and prepares to attack
luffy visibly confused by this luffy
keeps running and only in the last
moment reacts to shanks attack
the sky splits above elbaf and suddenly
shanks smiles he puts his arm around
luffy and congratulates him on his
accomplishments in wano as it turns out
he's the protector of elbaf and thanks
uzop for taking care of things in his
absence
that night the straw hats and the red
hair pirates have their first big
banquet together luffy and shanks now on
one level with each other during the
festivities a dark shape walks into town
as he reaches the fires we can see his
face
arrived who has sought out his old rival
after the abandonment of the warlord
system together with perona who bring
news that blackbeard is on his way to
elbaf as well and will arrive in a
couple of days
as if these news didn't matter at all
shanks invites mihawk to drink and while
perona reunites with zorro he reveals
that he's in possession of the last rode
pony glyph and challenges luffy to a
davey backfight for it to test his
strength and that of his crew we then
get a number of great contests between
the straw hats and the red hair pirates
where each of them shows off their
skills and proves their worth including
the long-awaited match between zorro and
mihawk after teaching everyone new
tricks and techniques and giving luffy
some pieces of advice shanks and the
others push luffy to leave the island
before blackbeard arrives in order to
give luffy a head start for left tail
but also as the patron of elbaf he will
stay and face the man who gave him his
scar
probably things will turn out quite
differently but i hope you enjoyed this
version of events nonetheless you should
click here if you want to learn more
about usop's role in elbaf and why he
might unlock conquerors hockey
[Music]